for today's classic interview we're
going back to an interview I did back in
January of 2013 four years ago with
Michael Parenti and we talked about
imperialism we talked about media we
talked about class and so many and many
other issues that are feeling so
relevant today under the trump
administration in ways that I could only
imagine in a very hypothetical sense
when I actually spoke to Michael Parenti
back in 2013 so let's get into this
interview from January of 2013 with
Michael Parenti joining me is Michael
Parenti noted political scholar also
author of his latest book the face of
imperialism Michael it's really a
pleasure to have you on the show today
I think a good place to start would be
to talk about how media coverage and how
it shapes political discourse has
shifted over recent decades maybe from
where it was in the 50 60 s going to
where we are today would you
characterize the change in the effects
of media on on politics I think we
should keep in mind that the major
mainstream media are not independent
players in the political game they are
not only close to corporate America not
only friendly into corporate America
they are a component of corporate
America I mean they're giant
corporations that on their boards of
directors they're [ __ ] the CEOs of
various different corporations of oil
industry the auto industry
transportation Monsanto is they actually
sit on the boards of the big companies
of a company like Fox is the personal
instrument of a self-described radical
conservative by the name of Rupert
Murdoch and they follow a very far-right
view so so they reflect the people who
own them they are they serve the people
on them an addiction they are influenced
by the government that they supposed to
be critically reporting about the
national security state the US CIA the
FBI they too have exercised
influences as to what they will put out
to the media what and how the media will
cooperate with them and when they ask
you to kill a story how how how
reporters are aware that they can get
frozen out if they say or they ask
questions are too disturbing as the
press conferences for instance they'll
just be passed over they'll get a
reputation of asking troublesome or
really critical questions well then they
don't get they don't get any responses
they don't get any story so the media
are armed are the we always think of how
the media manipulates us but the media
themselves are manipulated by the powers
that be lifting advertisers anybody I
think what solvent drilling who made the
point that and any even the local media
a state miscible level any any anybody
who has any kind of serious economic
power is someone you don't write
critical stories about in your newspaper
or on your radio station and such well I
think it's interesting because when it
comes to the American two-party
political system one of the best ways to
avoid having a story covered by
mainstream media is to have Democrats
and Republicans essentially agree on it
right and I think we see this so
drastically with the issue of drones
drones are something that George W Bush
exploded a lot of the drone policy
president Obama has essentially
continued or grown it even further and
Mitt Romney would have done nothing
different and we basically have a
mainstream media that almost does not
discuss at least in any critical way the
use of drone warfare and its legality
that's correct if anything they
apologized for the crimes of the drones
that they say that war is war and
occasionally you know it did
voidable that occasionally an innocent
person will get killed they were there
well in fact they should have more
accurately report that over 90 percent
of the drone victims are innocent
civilians and small villages who don't
know don't don't could even find the
United States on a map let alone be a
mortal terrorist threat to us so in that
sense that's right they that they're
they're apologists for that for that
sort of thing you know the whole thing
the media often says that we cannot
avoid we don't intend to kill these
people those are unintentional deaths
and that happens in wars but you know
there is in civil society it did not
just intention or unintentional you
can't just shoot into a crowd to kill
one person and kill six others and say
oh but I didn't intend to kill those
other six that was unintentional there
is there is another concept in criminal
law and that liability and in civil law
liability is if you if you do things
that are inevitably going to hurt other
people innocent people you're liable for
that you know what you're doing you know
so if you drop a bomb saying I'm on I
want to kill a oh but I have no
intention of killing B C and B then then
that that's a poor poor defendant yeah I
hear that kind of thing in the media
they're apologists for things like
drones and you're right both Republicans
and Democrats take it and the media dare
not dare not make critical utterance of
the kind I just made so the problem we
basically have is if you have the two
political parties agreeing on an issue
you're going to greatly diminish the
amount of coverage it will get because
it is not controversial or fiery in the
eyes of corporate media at the same time
if it falls into the other category
which is Democrats and Republicans
disagree the only lens through which it
will be covered is through that that of
here is what Democrats think and here is
what Republicans think we
is also not a particularly enlightening
lens for interpreting the world visit no
you're right because the Republicans
have a far right wing position and their
view even when many of their issues are
accepted and gratified and followed by
the White House and they just keep
pushing further and further right and
the further and more extreme right they
go the more they shift over the center
of political gravity so they take the
far right and the Democrats now under
someone like Obama
I really have a right centric view so
what you have is a whole left wing a
whole other perspective or variety of
perspectives on the Left which are just
amputated and taken off and and and you
don't hear them in the media and that is
called objective coverage as the media
think is objective when they present the
issues that are being mouthed by the
political and economic leaders of the
country that seem as as objective and
what you're really getting through one
of the issues are eluding through here I
think is that of just the real Frank and
honest discussion of the basics of the
economic system that we have and we saw
interestingly with the entire Occupy
movement we saw that for the first time
really in a long time as economists
Richard Wolfe has said on this program a
discussion of capitalism more broadly
was all of a sudden existing it was very
very limited but phrases like income
inequality were for the first time in a
long time mentioned by politicians on
both sides of the aisle as something
real so to that extent were we right to
be surprised that there was this
injection of a new idea by occupy in
other words is it that missing from the
political discussion yes I thought it
was rather remarkable to hear actually
to hear statements made critically about
capitalism but even there the coverage
was heavily slanted the police were
treated very favorably that the police
got away with some terrible acts of
violence and such and these were willful
we're not usually with poor
you know we may have seen them on the
internet but they were not reported in
the mainstream media there was a
systematic suppression of the Occupy
movement that movement came out of
nowhere
I mean you got to hand it to the
American people that pounded with a
certain propaganda a certain
establishment viewpoint if you want yet
they were able to come around that
pinpoint and and respond with some
reality and say look that isn't what's
happening what we have today is 1%
controlling the wealth and the and the
well-being and the growth and income has
been monopolized by them over the last
20 years income inequality is is worse
than it ever was before
people are working harder and harder
just to stay in the same place if you're
working harder and harder to stay in the
same place you're not staying in the
same place you're you're falling behind
[Music]
and and that that sort of thing and
there was just EMA critique
they were critiques about people
actually uttering the word capitalism as
a whole system and questioning that
system who does it really work for whose
expense in the light and what we need is
some alternative public ownership of
things of social social programs human
services greater protection of the
environment all of these things all
these things were coming out and people
were just talking about that not to not
because the liberal media had
brainwashed them quite the opposite
there's no liberal media there's an
establishment mainstream corporate media
that's best box invention talking about
the liberal media in meaning they're not
always as reactionary as foxes but but
they're not they're not a really
critical of things certainly the last
thing I want to touch on is you've been
critical of some self-described
progressives who focus on race gender
and culture as aspects that are
informing both media coverage and
politics in the US and who have
downplayed the importance of class and
class power you
being very clear about that here in this
interview but talk a little bit about
how that that is a criticism you've made
of progressives but also how they're not
mutually exclusive in other words class
and class power relates to gender and
race as well well yes for about the last
40 years I would say they've been
talking about race and gender we're
talking about them in a way that denies
the reality of class as another
component and when they do talk about
class they talk about it as a
sociological category you know lifestyle
income level education level things like
that I I say we should be talking about
class as a social relationship and
that's what the Occupy movement did they
were saying there's one percent and
there's ninety nine percent they were
actually talking about the great divide
the great class divide that is we're
talking about how these groups relate to
to power and the means of power the
resources of power the resources of
power and the ownership and the wealth
of the society are owned by one group
and the rest of us must find that way
and try to work and earn earn a living
and feed ourselves from hand to mouth
that struggle that that's a class power
struggle and that should be also looked
at and many people on the Left did not
do not look at that they would also
understand then that many of the race
and I'm not suggesting people ignore
race nor am I suggesting that race and
gender oppression are not serious the
life-and-death things I mean women are
dying every day in the world because I
wrote a book called the culture struggle
and I talked about the global rape
culture
I mean drugs the world I wrote about
this several years ago but it's
described I have descriptions of the
stuff you hear happening in India today
or Pakistan the way women are treated
and even physically destroyed because
these maniacs and these fools are
operating so I don't want to say and and
was raised to you know we may not have
Jim Crow lynch mob rule and mobile we
still have an enormous number of black
youth getting killed by police for
various reasons or by others so those
are very real issues I don't my saying
the bright better side but also there's
a dimension of racism and dimension of
sexism that is linked to cook the class
power relationship to that is by
pressing people having really depressed
and repressed people who work for it at
a super exploitation level you you
maximize profits mentally with women and
with with blacks you can see what makes
them employable their willingness to
work for super exploitative wages so so
suspect ISM also feeds into the whole
question of crack and crack mallet and
we really should really be looking at
those issues because that your class
also determines the issues of empire
it also pre determines where our taxes
now money goes
it'll planes why we have troops in about
60 different countries why or why we
have invaded and intrude upon other
countries it's to make the world safe
for for corporate America up and that
all those issues are just ignored and
the phony issues that are presented to
us is or we go into these countries
because we argue manatorian and we are
concerned that the people in this
country are not doing too well when
George Herbert Walker Bush invaded
Somalia he said I'm going because
there's a famine and I want to help them
what when did he ever show any concern
for famine in Africa there was about
nine countries said what's up and but
Somalia just they just discovered
three-quarters of the country was rich
with oil and also that they had to make
a presence in Central Asia and and such
so but that they can't tell us in
American people they can't say come on
we want to go bump religious we want to
go kill these people
because we want to take it over and
increase the wealth for corporate
America look at the French doing the
same thing Dave right now in Niger and
in Mali Niger is one of the richest
countries in the world it has some of
the greatest uranium storage all the
same has been going for pittance very
cheaply going to fresh Niger is one of
the poorest country is one of the
richest and the poorest those are rich
in resources but weak they get they get
taken over and colonized and plundered
and Nyjah has been plundered by French
75 percent of French electricity is
nuclear unfortunately all of us with
that much safe none of us are safe with
that going on all right
sample of what I'm saying how all kinds
of things that are happening around the
world but all of em pipe through all of
that is part of a class power that
that's being pursued and and for class
interest for that one percent and it's
mentioned by the media who brought all
of these interventions absolutely we've
been speaking with Michael Parenti noted
political scholar the latest book is the
face of imperialism Michael it's been a
real pleasure thank you so much for
doing this thank you I'm sorry if I went
on and on there for a minute no it's uh
I couldn't have said it better myself
thank you haha